Hospital Consultants are set to take
industrial action tell us more about
that yeah that's right senior doctors in
England Mark these are these medical
Consultants will strike on the 20th and
21st of July next month these are
members of the British Medical
Association as I say affecting
Consultants who are members of that
Union and working within England 86 of
their membership voted yes they had a 71
turnout so that's more than 24
000 of their Consultants voted in the
VMAs ballot effectively this is going to
be a 48 hour walkout affecting routine
services but we understand that
emergency care will be covered but this
is as I say plan strike action it will
result in so-called Christmas Day
Services what does that mean either
won't be any routine surgery or
appointments and let's remember this
will come now these two days at the end
of the junior doctor's strike because
they're planning to go on strike from
the 13th of July until the 18th of July
effectively wiping out a week of
elective surgery
yeah it would be interesting to know
exactly what Emergency Care means in
those circumstances but uh I mean the
bigger picture is Junior doctors still
taking strike action and uh and now this
move by the nurses some good news for
the government what's the reaction to
that more broadly well the reaction from
the government to up until that
announcement there from the VMA the
latest we'd heard is that they were
really quite elated that certainly when
it came to the nurses the Royal College
of Nursing had been planning to once
again ballot their members and
um with the theory of uh taking more
industrial action days leading up to
Christmas that has now been called off
they haven't reached the threshold to be
able to do so largely other health
unions had so far accepted the
government's latest pay deal but up
until in the last few hours the nurses
had been holding out they held this
ballot postal votes landed on doorsteps
over the last few weeks the ballot
closed on Friday
and they they weren't able to reach that
threshold they needed a voter turnout of
more than 50 they only got 43 of that 43
percent of nurses in England uh 84 of
them said they wanted to take uh strike
action but because they didn't meet that
threshold they can't take any further
action it brings an end to any form of
campaign by the RCN to hold any form of
industrial action but now the question
is are they going to accept the
government's five percent pay deal which
is currently on the table for them and
other health unions the only outstanding
Union that hasn't said they are happy to
take on that pay increase plus a one-off
payment is unite so RCN very much
disappointment from their perspective
they really wanted this strike action to
take place but suddenly when it comes to
the BMA and those medical Consultants
that is going ahead on the 20th and 21st
of July